SCP foundation creative works are
distributed according to the terms of
creative commons attribution share-alike
3.0 unported open license
this license allows everyone to use
these works as they see fit as long as
the terms of license are adhered to
hello everyone so I want to talk to you
today about something pretty concerned
and involved in the state of SCP and
Russia the Russian SCP issued a
statement this morning about a gentleman
called
Andrei dachshund if you don't know who
he is he is responsible for the Arte SCP
project it was an art book based on SCP
foundation materials
mr. dachshund has been in contact with
the SCP wiki since June 2015 in regards
to this project but it has been revealed
that between summer 2017 and 2018 he
attempted and succeeded in registering a
trademark for the SCP foundation logo
meaning that in Russia and the other
Eurasian customs union countries such as
Kazakhstan Belarus Armenia and
Kyrgyzstan this man controls all SCP
media and is free to pursue any legal
action he desires towards anyone he
desires just to put this into
perspective if this were to go any
further geographically speaking which I
doubt it will but but I just want to
make this point that means in theory
content creators like me SCP Illustrated
Lord bung games like SCP secret
laboratory on SCP containment bridge I'm
kind less other beloved SCP Media right
there could all be shut down or need to
pay royalties to whoever owns this
trademark to make the content that
thousands of people enjoy which would
result in the death of this fandom
eventually I am sure all of you do not
want this to happen I mentioned earlier
that at the moment this event is limited
to the Eurasian customs union countries
Kazakhstan Russia Belarus Armenia and
Kyrgyzstan so you may be asking why am I
talking about this bringing this to your
attention and that's because this kind
of attempt cannot be allowed to stand
and we as a fandom need to let anyone
like Andrzej dachshund know that this
kind of behavior is not acceptable or in
the spirit of the SCP found them the SCP
foundation belongs to all of us not one
single person we all make this find them
what it is
one person does not have the moral or
legal right to control any single part
of it I'd also like to quickly mention
some of the most common defenses of
Andres conduct Andre has put huge
amounts of money into developing the
foundation universe his investments
deserve to be protected he forfeited his
right for any of his investment to be
protected the moment he tried to claim
personal ownership of a fondant that has
existed for 10 plus years and kind less
people have contributed to he creates
good art but so does thousands of people
that contribute that has found him he is
not special Andre has done a lot for the
foundation raised its popularity
immensely shared several unique projects
without peer you have no right to treat
him like this Andre has created art as
have countless others the Shira might
have talented people creating unique
content for this fandom
is unbelievable I don't care who you are
nobody gets a free pass to do whatever
they want with this condom so what do we
do about this well the legal side has
been professionally dealt with by the
Russian and English branches of their CP
wiki but as a community we need to let
people know that we will not stand for
this kind of behavior I will say
publicly right now that from this moment
onward I won't be supporting anything
Andre Ducks and creates
as I found them ultimately we vote with
our time and money and I will be
offering any of mine to him if you would
like to read in detail about what has
happened the link to the official
statement will be in the video
description help protect our foundation
because if we don't no one else will
thanks for listening
you